INTRO:
Ever since Putin invaded Ukraine, the world
has bombarded Russia with sanctions, restrictions,
and limitations.
In terms of transportation, Boeing, Airbus,
Ford, Mercedes, Toyota, and Volkswagen have
all suspended exports/and or stopped operations
in Russia.
In terms of tech, Apple has halted all product
sales, Google has demonetized Russian state
media, and Facebook and TikTok have blocked
Russian state media altogether in Europe.
In terms of energy, Exxon, Shell, BP, and
Equinor have announced that they will be canceling
investments in Russia and/or leaving Russia
completely.
In terms of logistics, UPS and FedEx have
halted shipments to Russia and Ukraine.
In terms of finances, several Russian banks
have been barred from the SWIFT system, and
Switzerland has frozen Russian assets.
And that doesn’t even include the countrywide
bans on bonds, airspace restrictions, and
limitations on Russian banks and oligarchs.
Considering all this, there’s no question
that once everything is said and done in Ukraine,
Russia is screwed economically.
In fact, in just the past 1 month, the USD
to Ruble exchange rate has exploded from 75
rubles per dollar to over 120 rubles per dollar.
This means that the Russian Ruble has lost
nearly 40% of its value against the dollar.
Meanwhile, the Russian stock market crashed
33% the day after the invasion even with the
Russian central bank closing the stock market.
And at the time of making this video, Russia
has refused to reopen the market in fear of
even greater losses.
So, how screwed really is the Russian economy?
ECONOMIC SPIRAL:
We hear all this news about sanctions and
restrictions on Russia, but what does this
really do to the economy?
Well, from a consumer’s perspective, it
seems like you just can’t travel as much
abroad, and you can’t buy certain foreign
goods.
But, the true consequences are much more deep-rooted
and painful with the first being uncontrollable
inflation.
Like any other product on the market, the
Russian Ruble is subject to supply and demand
constraints.
And the value of the Ruble in relation to
other currencies is dependent on how many
people want the Ruble vs the other currency.
When a country is exporting a bunch of goods
like Russia, a lot of countries and companies
will need the Ruble to purchase Russian goods.
But, when basically every Russian good is
blocked from being imported, the demand for
the Ruble falls off a cliff.
In the meantime, Russians are still dependent
on a lot of foreign goods including basics
like food, clothing, and medicine.
And in order to obtain these essentials, Russians
must give up rubles in exchange for dollars,
euros, or whatever the case may be.
Russia has tried to soften this demand by
limiting imports into the country.
But, with how interconnected the global economy
is today, it’s nearly impossible to break
away and become independent.
This means that the supply of rubles from
Russians hasn’t really changed all that
much while the demand for the ruble from foreigners
has evaporated.
And basic economics would tell you that this
screws over the Ruble, and that’s why it
has dropped nearly 40% in the past few weeks.
But uncontrollable inflation is not even that
bad when you consider that the entire financial
system is in danger of collapsing.
You see, not only do sanctions limit the demand
for rubles, but it makes it extremely difficult
to access rubles that are stored in foreign
countries.
Ever since 2014, Russia’s central bank has
been building up massive positions in foreign
currencies.
It’s estimated that they hold $630 billion
in foreign currencies.
This was a strategic move to protect Russia
against inflation, but this has kind of backfired.
The $630 billion worth of foreign currency
is worth significantly more than if they had
just held that money in rubles.
But, given all these sanctions, they don’t
actually have access to this money.
Not only does this make it more difficult
for Russia to fund their activities, but more
importantly, they’re now facing a massive
liquidity problem.
And given that this is public knowledge, Russian
banks are scrambling to prevent a bank run.
One of these countermeasures was raising interest
rates from 9.5% to 20%.
This is truly quite amusing.
Over here in the US, the stock market is throwing
a fit because Powell might increase interests
rates by half a percent after months of heads
up.
But, Russia literally raised interest rates
by 10.5% overnight.
Russia is hoping that 20% interest rates will
convince Russians to keep their money in the
bank and that they can avoid a bank run.
But, the situation is still extremely fragile,
and one big catalyst could destroy the Russian
financial system.
INFLATION SPIRAL:
Even if Russia is able to avoid a full-on
financial collapse, the next several years
will still be quite painful anyway.
You see, when a bunch of everyday goods rise
in price by 40%, people will need to spend
significantly more money on living expenses.
For many everyday Russians, this means withdrawing
from savings and/or going broke.
In the meantime, businesses will have to pay
significantly more for their goods which means
that they’ll have to raise prices on their
products just to stay afloat.
But, by raising prices, a lot of their customers
would no longer be able to afford these goods
which means that they’ll get less business
and may end up going bankrupt anyway.
Businesses that do survive will have to pay
their employees significantly higher salaries
which means that they’ll probably be more
conservative when it comes to hiring, and
they might even let go of a few employees.
Not only does this dramatically increase the
workload for the remaining employees, but
this will dramatically increase unemployment.
And when more people are unemployed, consumers
as a whole will spend less money which means
even less revenue for businesses which could
lead to another round of layoffs and then
the cycle starts over.
Also, what about the well-off Russians?
I’m not talking about the billionaire oligarchs,
but the everyday millionaires that worked
saved, and invested for 40 50 years just to
attain some level of financial freedom.
At this rate, these individuals will have
to return to work very soon.
Something else to consider is that the inflation
that Russia has seen so far could just be
the beginning.
About 25 years ago, in 1998, Russia experienced
a similar financial fallout due to a different
set of circumstances.
Things got so bad that Russia ended up defaulting
on domestic debt which led to the Ruble jumping
off a cliff.
Before the crisis, you could get 1 US dollar
using 5-6 Rubles, but after the crisis, you
needed 30 rubles to just get a single dollar.
This means that by the time things stabilized,
the Ruble had lost 80 to 90% of its value.
If we see something similar right now, each
US dollar could be equivalent to 400 rubles
by the end of this crisis.
And that’s if things end up stabilizing.
The 1998 financial crisis was not a result
of the world powers trying to punish Russia.
It was due to unsustainable economic and financial
practices similar to the 2008 financial recession.
So, for the most part, no one was trying to
intentionally screw over Russia, but the same
cannot be said about the current situation.
So, if worse comes to worst, it’s possible
that Russia enters hyperinflation on the scale
of Venezuela, Zimbabwe, and Germany after
WW1.
And at that point, there’s really nothing
left to do but start over.
So, even if the Russian economy doesn’t
implode due to sanctions, it’s possible
that the economy bleeds out due to hyperinflation.
STOCK MARKET SPIRAL:
The collateral damage of a financial crisis
and inflation alone is horrendous, but we
haven’t even discussed the future of the
Russian stock market and its collateral damage.
At the time of making this video, Russia is
yet to reopen the stock market, but a lot
of Russian stocks are available on different
exchanges like the London Stock exchange.
And so far, they have lost 33% of their value
which correlates to a $200 billion loss in
market cap.
That makes this crash the 5th worst crash
in stock market history.
And that’s with the London exchange suspending
Russian stocks.
If London hadn’t suspended these stocks,
it’s quite possible that these stocks would
be down over 50% by now.
For a lot of you guys, it might be confusing
as to how the stock market affects the average
Russian given that the average Russian likely
doesn’t own many stocks.
Well, even though the average Russian may
not incur direct losses on stock holdings,
they will likely face several indirect consequences.
To understand this, we have to first take
a look at why the stock market is even crashing
in the first place.
The answer, in this case, is obvious.
With all these sanctions and restrictions,
it’s unlikely that most Russian companies
will be able to pull in the revenue and profits
that they used to.
Many of these companies will no longer be
profitable and will be headed towards bankruptcy.
And given that low investor trust in Russia,
it’s gonna be nearly impossible for these
companies to raise money by selling shares.
This leaves them with only two options.
Either they can fight for profitability until
they go bankrupt at which point they’ll
have to shut down operations and lay off all
their employees.
Or, they’ll have to get a bailout from the
government which would simply increase the
odds of hyperinflation.
Neither of these options is particularly favorable
to the average person.
Either they lose their job or they lose their
savings.
And what about retirees?
Most retirees in Russia depend on various
pension and retirement plans, and these plans
have investments in the stock market.
With the stock market halving in values and
their foreign assets being frozen, it’s
gonna be a lot harder for these funds to pay
out their millions of beneficiaries.
These funds may be forced to default or borrow
money to pay out their beneficiaries.
And given that Russian interest rates are
as high as credit cards right now, you definitely
don’t want to be borrowing money.
As you can see, even though the average Russian
may not directly have stock holdings, a stock
market crash would be pretty painful for them
as well.
ECONOMIC WAR:
At the end of the day, the west doesn’t
agree with Putin’s invasion of Ukraine,
and this has caused them to take severe action.
100 years ago, the west may have entered into
war against Russia or entered into an arms
race against Russia.
But, today, governments are trying to address
this situation diplomatically.
Instead of fighting a deadly war or building
up weapons of mass destruction, the west is
trying to get Russia to back off by threatening
their economy.
And with the biggest countries and companies
on board, it seems to be pretty effective
in causing economic damage.
However, it’s unclear if this will actually
lead to Russia backing down.
Here’s the thing, even if they did back
down, Putin has permanently burned a lot of
bridges by deciding to invade.
So, it’s unlikely that their economy will
just return to normal if they leave Ukraine.
Considering this, if the Russian economy is
screwed either way, why not make a statement
on your way out.
And it looks like that’s what Putin has
chosen to do.
Looking forward, it’s unlikely that the
Russian economy will completely collapse or
enter hyperinflation, though those do have
non-negligible probabilities.
The more likely scenario is that Russia falls
down another tier amongst world powers economically
with the everyday Russian bearing most of
the fallout.
While that’s quite a shame, hopefully, all
these efforts make it substantially harder
for Putin to invade yet another country.
But only time will tell.
Do you guys think the Russian economy is screwed?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you feel bad for the
everyday Russian.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.